people in Khartoum are desperate to get
out Gathering whatever they can carry
they're seeking safety wherever they can
find it many have already crossed into
Chad more are likely to follow we could
weakness with our own ways the hundreds
and hundreds of people that I had just
left the village in Sudan and this
particularly was one Village named
tindulti and and they came to chant to
an area that is extremely poor there is
no more service available no medical
service no water
nothings Chad has its own problems
conflict and climate change have left
more than 2 million people struggling to
get enough to eat and it's already
hosting hundreds of thousands of
refugees who fled conflicts in the
region
eight agencies fear there won't be
enough to go around we are dispatching
um a convoy of food aid for 10 000
people only for two months or 20 000
people for one month and and it's very
complex we are borrowing from a project
from another and but we really need
support we cannot continue like this
back in Sudan the violence has been
escalating and both sides are refusing
to talk
those fleeing the fighting have no way
of knowing if or when they'll see their
homes again
Fenton Monaghan Al Jazeera